in order to get
some sense of what philosophers do
whether we're talking about contemporary
philosophers those teaching philosophy
explaining it commenting on it or the
many philosophers that comprise the vast
history and the interlocking
conversations
that we assemble under that
name it might be helpful to spend a
little bit of time
talking and thinking about some of the
common elements of philosophical work
some of the things that you see
across not just philosophical schools
but even time
space cultures because all of these are
going to
show up more or less in
work that we consider philosophy and in
current contemporary philosophy
so this is not an absolutely
comprehensive list we're not attempting
to
detail the entire philosophical
toolbox as if we were a hardware store
with aisles
going down them and looking at every
single possible
instrument that we might use but it's
just to give you a sense of some of the
big
things that we we often do bring up and
i've brought some of these together
under some headings where i think
there's at least some
some commonalities or connections so the
first one to
start talking about is doctrines theses
principles we might also talk about
judgments or you know dogmas
there's a lot of different terminology
that gets used for this
generally these are going to be
propositions that
sometimes actually get laid out in
something like a manifesto
or a listing and you know
philosophy is to a significant extent
the articulation of doctrines the things
that are being taught the things that
are being
expressed as representations of how
things
actually are according to a particular
philosopher
or school or we might also present
somebody else's doctrines in order to
say well they're getting
things wrong but here's what they think
theses
is a similar way a thesis is something
that is
set down or set forward i believe
that freedom is important and we need to
understand it better so that we can
afford everybody at least the
opportunity for freedom well that's
that's a thesis that could also be
understood as a doctrine
it could also be understood as a
principle a principle
usually when we're talking about
philosophy is identified as something
that you're going to use at the start
and argue from or develop
from some other ideas some other
theses and doctrines and these can be
kind of
interchangeable with each other there is
a sense of greater priority to
principles but one person's principle
might be another person's spurious
doctrine
and and vice versa so that's an
important part being able to say well
what does aristotle
actually have to say what does aristotle
clearly think about this
that might be expressed in in terms of
those and very often
philosophers will clarify this
for us in some modes of philosophizing
they're
very bent on being super clear about
this and others we have to work for it a
good bit
more and sometimes ideas
get framed and attributed to
philosophers
that they don't actually say but
interpreters
will read in like you know the thesis
of the uh unity of the virtues right
eris level doesn't actually use that
term but people
talk about that sometimes they'll say
the doctrine
or the argument right that takes us to
another thing so let's talk now about
the next one definitions
and essences so the essence of something
if something does have an essence would
be
what makes it what it is and a
definition
is an attempt to in some way express
or articulate the the essence
of something and these very often are
things we have to work
towards rather than immediately
beginning
with knowing evidently or going to a
dictionary philosophy
consists in a significant extent in
working
with these and trying to make sense of
them
it's important too to recognize that the
same
term may not have the same meaning
moving from one philosopher to another
or from another one philosophical
school to another all of these slippery
terms
that have we we call them ambiguous or
polysemis they have different
ranges of meaning we have to be careful
with them some of these are very
important philosophical
terms or concepts like substance what is
it to be a substance
ask aristotle get one answer ask
nietzsche get another answer
ask the stoics get another answer we we
could go on and on but they will have
something in common it's not
totally arbitrary but we do have to
spend some time working on that and
that's that's an important tool of
philosophy once we have things
that are good working definitions we can
go forward from there we can use them in
a kind of deductive way we can say well
that that implies this or
this case over here seems to fit the
definition this case over here doesn't
analogies and examples this is actually
one of my favorite parts
of the discipline of philosophy
when we make analogies we're saying that
there's some sort of
similarity or derivation relation
between
things so you know aristotle will will
actually talk about
analogia as will other philosophers like
for example
seneca here's a prime example
seneca uses the word analogy to describe
how we get our conception of these great
character traits that are the virtues we
don't begin with definitions and
essences
we see people doing extraordinary things
displaying
traits of character and we're like wow
that's courage
i'm actually seeing it and then we
analogize
from that to well what would that be
like in
our own life you know battlefield
courage not every one of us has to be on
the battlefield but maybe we do have to
stand up to bullies
or we do have to give a speech or we do
have to
say something to a friend that's quite
difficult for us
to say because we're afraid of the
consequences that's an analogy right
and analogies cover a vast field
examples are very very important i i
tend to think that this is
if for a practitioner philosophy who's
teaching
being able to come up with good examples
and then lead students through them and
see the weak points you know where the
example breaks down or the analogy
breaks down
and the similarities that's a really
important skill
and in saying that i am echoing the many
people who called attention to
anselm of canterbury and his
extraordinary ability to do this
on the spot so that's that's
often less a matter of pure intellect
and much more a matter of
imagination as and you know being able
to reach an audience
but analogy analogies and examples
really do help us
conceptualize these more abstract things
that we're working with in philosophy
they root us to the
the ground that we're working on
hypothetical inferences and thought
experiments
somewhat connected with the idea of
examples a thought experiment
is a little bit more well worked out we
say imagine to yourself
an island in which this is the case
and then we say well what would be the
consequences of that or
how would how would the world be
different or how would you
deal with this sort of situation another
classic thought experiment the trolley
problem right
a trolley is going out of control down
the tracks
and it will run over five people who are
tied to the tracks unless
you flip a switch which diverts it so it
kills only one person
what do you do well that's a thought
experiment right
and there's a variety of those and we
can think of thought experiment
experiments as being kind of like
analogies and examples but also like
being hypothetical inferences
where you say let's assume x is the case
what follows from that now with
hypothetical inferences we might be
doing that because we say
we don't actually have direct knowledge
of this but let's imagine this is the
case what would follow from this
i mean you could actually take kant's
first critique is involving a lot of
that
right if this is going to be the case as
we call this transcendental critique
uh then what has to also be the case we
could do this when we want to refute an
opponent's position
or weaken their position we say well
you're saying this
but if we assume that this is the case
then
your doctrine is going to lead to
something false or something
bad or something we don't want to arrive
at and so
hypothetical inferences can serve all
sorts of purposes but we do a lot of
this
again to bring up emanuel kant if you
think about the
categorical imperative it's first
formulation we ask well
what would it be like if everybody
did this action that i'm proposing to do
and students will often get hung up on
this and they say
yeah but everybody doesn't do that we
said that's that's completely correct
but what would it be like what would
follow from that
right and being able to do this is also
like with analogies and examples a
matter not just of intellect
but also of imagination and perhaps even
empathy or compassion depending on what
sort of inferences and experiments
were working with another really key
aspect of philosophy and
this is one in which my practical work
as
a professional philosopher outside of
academia
has shown to me just how characteristic
this is
of philosophy and how important it is
is being able to make distinctions and
then show what follows from the
distinction
sometimes this can be as simple as
sitting at a table with two people that
are talking about
some sort of process in their workplace
and both of them are arguing with each
other and saying no you're wrong no
you're wrong
and then you say listen you're both
using this same
term but you're using it in this way
and you're using it in this way you're
using it with two different senses
let's make a distinction here you're
partly right you're partly right and
they're like it's magic
no it's not magic it's just the
operation of
making distinctions which is partly an
operation of the intellect being able to
slice things down and could be a
distinction
two things it could be you know
distinction between three things it
could be a whole bunch
of distinctions sometimes we can say
you're talking on this level
you're talking on this higher metal
level about the same thing
so it's really very important a prime
example of this
when aristotle is considering the nature
of friendship he says
let's make a distinction based on
the goods that the friendship is in
terms of some friendships are
genuine friendships in terms of the
character of the people themselves
these are the closest most paradigmatic
kinds of friendships
but a lot of friendships are friendships
of pleasure we're friends with people
because
we get pleasure out of it and we give
pleasure to them
some it's not even pleasure it's
usefulness or
benefit in in some way and you know each
of these is a distinct
kind of friendship well that's making
distinctions right
inquiries explanations and accounts when
we talk about
inquiring and it could be spelled with
an e or an i
right inquiring into something
seeking out the the truth about
something trying to figure things out
that's what we're engaged in a lot of
the time in philosophy we're asking
things like well what does thomas hobbes
actually think
is thomas hobbes actually right in what
he thinks
what about what so and so has to say
what about our own experience is that
confirmed
does that confirm rather or disconfirm
what this this person over here
has to say how does the world become
richer or poorer as we're applying
this mode of thinking providing
explanations for why things are the way
they are or why they aren't the way
that we think they should be right or
what's actually going on
in a thinker's writings and the the
statements that they're making all of
these
sorts of things accounts being able to
say well this is this is what is
here's what's going on when we feel a
sense of remorse
having done something wrong is that a
purely subjective feeling
or does that reflect anything out there
in the world that is
pressing upon us well that's something
we could give a philosophical account of
we call those the moral
emotions right and so that that is
what a lot of philosophizing is doing
and accounts will incorporate
doctrines definitions analogies all
these other
sorts of things sometimes the emphasis
is more on the activity
of producing these sometimes yet the
emphasis will be
on the final product you know we can't
talk with emmanuel kant anymore he's
long dead
but we can read his books and see what
he has to say
likewise you know his contemporary mary
wollstonecraft
we can as i have my students do every
semester when i teach her
we can say the things that she was
making criticisms of in terms of culture
the distinctions between men and women
and what they are able to do does that
apply today or does that
have we gotten past that when we bring
these texts into the
present we are bringing along inquiry
explanations and accounts finally
another
really really key central aspect of
philosophy
argumentation and arguments not exactly
the same thing
think of argumentation as broader
there's all these different
strategies and ways of arranging things
that we
we do in order to make our cases in
order to articulate
what it is that we want to say with all
of these other things
sometimes we make quite explicit
arguments sometimes we even label them
as arguments i should point out that the
the
meaning of argument has become
you know more focused recently
it's got a broader sense throughout
uh history of philosophy so that
an argument argument might actually
consist of a whole bunch of other
arguments
but it has a logical structure that we
can represent
and examine and weaken or strengthen
arguments can be defeated arguments can
be
strengthened and supported in other ways
these are very there's a whole range of
things
that we do with arguments and we do this
whether we're talking about metaphysics
or epistemology
these more theoretical disciplines or
whether we're talking about
you know trying to produce attitudes
actions
choices priorities policies in political
philosophy in aesthetics
in philosophy of sports
pick whatever it is that that you want
and so
the arguments argumentation another very
important part of philosophy
all of these are things that you're
going to see
philosophers using talking about
engaging in as you look at their
writings and as you start doing some
philosophy of your own
you will find yourself engaging in these
as well
you